au 1er janvier dans le cadre de la
réforme territoriale et de la loi dite
d'affirmation des métropoles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'agrandit
villepreux coignières maurepas plaisir
et les clayes-sous-bois c'est tout le
fonctionnement de la communauté
d'agglomération qui doit évoluer
nouvelles compétences nouveau service
changement d'interlocuteur
vous êtes perdus pas de panique votre
magazine vous décrypte cette
métamorphose et vous expliquer
concrètement ce qui va changer pour vous
me suivez
et
depuis 2014 une importante réforme
territoriale entend transformer pour
plusieurs décennies larchitecture du
territoire de la république
en jeu la baisse des dépenses publiques
et une meilleure prise en compte des
besoins citoyen au coeur de ce processus
d'aménagement du territoire la
décentralisation des compétences
administratives de l'état vers les
collectivités locales
cet été le parlement français a
promulgué une nouvelle loi appelée loi
notre visant à clarifier les compétences
des différents échelons territoriaux de
la commune de l'intercommunalité du
département ou de la région qui fait
quoi
certaines compétences sont imposés par
la loi à toutes les intercommunalités de
france
d'autres ne le sont pas c'est ensuite
aux représentants des communes de
l'intercommunalité de décider si telle
ou telle compétence sera désormais géré
par l'intercommunalité ou restera à la
charge de la commune
c'est le travail qui a été fait au cours
de ces derniers mois avec l'ensemble des
maires qui ont travaillé de manière
ardue mais efficace aussi puisque nous
sommes arrivés sans aucun problème à un
quasi accord sur la totalité de tous ces
sujets ce qui va être important pour les
collectivités que ce soit les villes
l'agglomération de
saint quentin c'est qu'il y aura de
mutualisation importante
donc c'est vrai que quand on va traiter
des kilomètres de voirie supplémentaires
forcément nous allons obtenir des prix
qui seront plus compétitifs
donc du coup tout le monde sera gagnant
à saint quentin
il existe le coc des skis un comité
réunissant de nombreux habitants et
représentants de la société civile son
rôle est purement consultatif mais les
membres ne se prive pas de donner leur
point de vue sur les changements à venir
et d'être force de proposition très
concrètement vous vous réveillez le 1er
janvier l'espace rien vous pouvez faire
le réveillon tranquillement la
différence elle va apparaître
progressivement parce qu'il va y avoir
donc la constitution d'un nouveau
conseil communautaire qui va
définir progressivement un certain
nombre d'actions qui vont être qu'ils
vont être nouvelle alors pour les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
il est assez probable qu' il y aura pas
de changement majeur dans les dents les
compétences exercées par l'agglomération
en revanche pour les communes qui
rejoignent les sept communes de saint
quentin en yvelines là pour plusieurs de
ses compétences les habitants vont avoir
en quelque sorte un autre interlocuteur
au lieu que les services certains
services soient traitées par la commune
ils seront traités par l'agglomération à
l'ouest parisien rien de nouveau
pas vraiment je vous propose de passer
en revue certaines des principales
compétences de la future grande
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et commençons
tout de suite par le réseau de transport
les maires des douze communes devront
désormais analyser ensemble les besoins
de la population saint-quentinoise en
fonction des nouveaux quartiers qui vont
se construire et ce pour faciliter le
déplacement entre les différentes gares
les cinq communes qui vont nous
rejoindre vont travailler avec nous pour
définir leurs besoins et pour
effectivement que la nouvelle communauté
d'agglo puissent irriguer en fonction
des besoins des populations les nouveaux
territoires donc très certainement ça
changera la vie des usagers qui
effectivement pourront bénéficier d'un
service complémentaire et renforcer donc
à 12
l'agglomération a plus de poids pour
faire valoir ses besoins et pour
négocier avec la région une amélioration
des services rendus par le hair vers les
fréquences des fréquences le soir ou
dans notre creuse aussi peut-être pour
peser pour avancer le calendrier de la
réalisation de la ligne 18
du métro du grand paris des lignes de
transport supplémentaires des fréquences
de passages de bus ou le train augmenté
sur le papier le projet a de quoi
réjouir les habitants qu'ils soient
nouveaux entrants ou déjà saint
quentinois
mais la compétence transport ne se
résume pas uniquement au transport en
commun par exemple les investissements
pour la construction de nouveaux
franchissements de voies ferrées pour
désengorger les goulets d'étranglement
aux heures de pointe et bien ceux ci
seront désormais du ressort de
l'intercommunalité
entretien de la voirie des espaces verts
éclairage public fourniture en eau
potable traitement des eaux usées tous
ces services urbains et techniques liées
à la ville continueront d'être traité
par la communauté d'agglomération et la
nouveauté c'est la collecte et le
traitement des ordures ménagères qui
rejoint la longue liste des compétences
obligatoires de l'intercommunalité
très concrètement ça veut dire un réseau
de déchetteries qui va se construire les
admis ce raid du territoire pourront
bénéficier de l'ensemble des déchets tri
du territoire et on espère aussi
améliorer les services rendus aux
administrés puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est des
prestations qui sont assez variables
d'une collectivité à l'autre
donc on montera progressivement en
charge pour offrir le même service à
tous les administrés et pourquoi pas si
nous sommes de bons négociateurs avec
les effets d'échelle peut être un
service de qualité et moins cher
côté culture la communauté
d'agglomération poursuit et renforce le
développement de la lecture publique
avec l'arrivée des nouvelles communes le
réseau de médiathèques passe de sept à
douze établissements
ce fonctionnement en réseau va
simplifier la vie de l'ensemble des
usagers de ces nouveaux territoires qui
pourront aller réceptionner des ouvrages
à côté de leur lieu de domicile par
exemple à la médiathèque de plaisir et
puis la restituer à la médiathèque de
montigny ou de lui en cours si par
exemple du travail là bas
côté activité là aussi quelques
bénéfices se profile à l'horizon
essentiellement pour les habitants des
nouvelles communes en 30
c'est le cas notamment à lille de
loisirs à partir du 1er janvier 2016
l'entrée de nouvelles communes dans le
territoire élargi de saint quentin en
yvelines va pouvoir permettre à ces
nouvelles communes aux habitants de
cette nouvelle commune de bénéficier de
trois entrées gratuites par an tout
comme les saint quentinois
nous offrons depuis deux années
maintenant les services d'ap
c'est à dire sur le temps d'activités
périscolaires nos services se rendent
dans les écoles du territoire et au-delà
donc les nouvelles communes en 30 vont
pouvoir bénéficier de ce service là pour
pouvoir bénéficier les activités
sportives ou activités en lien avec les
activités développées à la ferme
les élus locaux y sont attachés à leur
relation de proximité avec le tissu
associatif
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
associations continueront de dépendre
des communes la communauté
d'agglomération elle soutiendra les
grosses associations d'envergure
communautaire ou qui comme pour le sport
atteignent le haut niveau désormais
elles n'auront plus qu'un seul
interlocuteur à la communauté
d'agglomération
ce sera alors beaucoup plus simple pour
inscrire leurs dossiers de subventions
le point positif si on devait en retenir
un ce serait que finalement jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai toujours dit que il y
avait un peu trop de saupoudrage sur les
différentes communes de la communauté
d'agglomération
cette commune aujourd'hui douze communes
demain et à ce titre là ça suppose que
les clubs se parlent enfin j'ai toujours
pensé qu'on ne se parlaient pas
suffisamment qui avait pas suffisamment
d'école une des chaînes qui soient
proposées en fonction des clubs
en gros ça ça tombe bien c'est que dans
cette période là alors on se retrouve on
se parle et pour moi c'est le but des
associations c'est le bien commun et 7
vivre ensemble
cette nouvelle agglomération a nécessité
des mois de travail pour que saint
quentin en yvelines soit encore plus
facile à vivre plus près de vous et avec
des services plus déficient alors prêt
pour ce nouveau départ
je tiens rassuré des habitants rien ne
va changer du jour au lendemain
ceux qui sont déjà dans une forte
intercommunalités comme la casse qui se
rendent bien compte comment les choses
se passent le tout c'est que le travail
soit effectué qu'ils soient effectués
par les services de la ville ou par les
services de la communauté
d'agglomération c'est pas le plus
important le plus important c'est de
service rendu et le service rendu sera
toujours le même où près de la
population
il sera même renforcé mutualiser les
moyens humains et financiers pour plus
de cohérence et d'efficacité c'est le
pari de la réforme territoriale
vous l'aurez compris au 1er janvier 2016
concevoir et mener un projet à l'échelle
de 12 communes devrait presque être un
jeu d'enfant
les institutions ont été créées leurs
compétences définies
de quoi donner de l'ambition à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines toujours plus
attractif et plus innovants de quoi
également renforcer le sentiment
d'appartenance des habitants des
entreprises des associations à un seul
et même territoire
sky mag c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
rendez vous le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
d'ici là portez vous bien